[Music]
what up guys goes on coming at you with
another attack on Titan video today we
are going to be ranking all of the nine
Titan powers from weakest to strongest
notice I said power and I users so
unlike my top 10 strongest attack on
Titan character list this list will
focus on the nine Titan powers
themselves rather than on how well the
powers are used by a specific character
if you want to see more attack on Titan
videos give that like button a colossal
Warhammer smash and let me know if
you're new to the channel make sure to
subscribe and ring that magic you do
bell so you don't miss any upcoming
videos this should be obvious at this
point but there are going to be manga
spoilers in this video now let me
mention some important information about
the rankings although some Titan powers
are weaker than others I want to stress
the fact that they are all useful in
their own way and each has certain
advantages and disadvantages that the
others don't have if we recall the
legendary Emir Fritz had all the powers
at one point before they got split into
nine so they were all an integral and
important part of her powers for the
purpose of this video we will be looking
at which Titan powers are weakest the
strongest in a one-on-one battle
scenario where the goal for each Titan
shifter is to kill the other Titan or
leave them incapacitated although the
hypothetical battles would be one
shifter versus another shifter we will
allow for powers that can control pure
Titans to be considered since that is an
important aspect of the attack on Titan
world and of certain Titan powers a
disclaimer before we begin I want to say
that there is still a lot of information
we don't know about the nine Titans so
there may still be secret abilities that
will be revealed later that may change
the ranking of this list furthermore the
experience of a user the setting of the
battle and other factors may change the
outcome of specific battles looking at
all the evidence in the anime and manga
this is my opinion if you disagree feel
free to let me know how you would rank
that in the comments now that we've set
the ground rules let's jump right into
it
number nine the car tighten despite the
fact that the car tighten gets made fun
of a lot
it has quite a few things going for it
it has the best endurance we know that
peak can maintain the form for months in
addition to that the car Titan is
insanely fast using this speed peak was
able to rescue Reiner and Zeek in the
return to Chicago Gina Ark however when
it comes to offense the car Titan is the
weakest it is good at transporting
materials on its back but not great for
attacking which is why the car Titan has
never done any serious damage to another
Titan shifter it is also the only other
Titan that needs artillery to be
equipped to it in battle in order to
make up for its weak offense the
endurance and speed makes the Titan good
at running away but in a battle to the
death with another shifter it would have
little chance of winning number eight
the armored Titan the armored Titan is
surrounded by armor like plates that
increase its defense and attack but slow
it down as well it is true that the
armored Titan could remove plates from
its joints to make it somewhat quicker
but the armor doesn't really help that
much when dealing with other Titans
because there are too many ways to
overcome the power in the first instance
that Aaron's attack Titan beat him he
used wrestling moves to crack his armor
in the rematch he used his newly
acquired hardening power to harden his
fists and this allowed him to break the
armor too in fact most of the Titans can
learn this hardening ability we know
that the female Titan Beast Titan JA
titan Warhammer Titan along with the
attack Titan can all use hardening
abilities that could help break through
the armor Titans defense for this reason
the armor in a fight against most other
Titan shifters really only serves to
slow this Titan down because every
shifter except the card Titan has a way
to crack it thus in a shifter versus
shifter fight I have to put the armored
Titan at number eight number seven the
female Titan the female Titan power can
also harden parts of her skin to deal
more fatal blows she has good endurance
and is quicker and more flexible than
the armored Titan
in addition she has the ability to
scream and attract pure Titans to her I
had to place her above the armored Titan
because the female Titan is capable of
using all of the moves that the attack
Titan used to defeat the armored Titan
she can be an expert fighter who might
also be capable of wrestling the armored
Titan into submission or if that fails
she can use her hardening powers to
break through the armor Titans armor as
a trump card she could also call pure
Titans to her lead them to the armored
Titan and proceed to avoid the puritans
more effectively in the armored Titan
who is slower because of his armored
plates for these reasons I have to place
the female Titan above the armored Titan
number 6 the attack Titan next I have
the attack Titan going off the manga I
have to place the attack Titan at number
6 the attack Titan has shown that he is
capable of defeating the armored Titan
many times even though Reiner the user
of the armored Titan was a more
experienced Titan shifter than Aaron was
but you might ask why I placed the
attack tine higher than the female Titan
since in the manga at least the attacked
I never had a clear victory against her
in fact in the manga it seemed like the
female Titan was beating the attack
Titan she had even removed one of his
arms and smashed his face before she
decided to start running away and
climbing up the walls
Mikasa however cut her down and the
attack Titan was able to move quick and
trap her to the ground after she fell
although it seemed like Annie won the
fight we should keep in mind at this
point and he had more fighting and Titan
experience than Darren furthermore she
couldn't get a decisive win over the
attack Titan and decided that she needed
to run away instead also clearly the
attack Titan was nowhere near out of gas
since he was ready to spring when
Annie's Titan hit the ground combined
these factors with the fact that the
attack Titan has a larger more muscular
build than the female Titan and I think
the attack Titan Power has to be
considered the stronger Titan power it
is worth mentioning that Ehren Kruger
the user of the attack Titan before
Aaron and his dad appeared to get a
glimpse of the future at one point
is quite the amazing ability if it is
unique to the attack tightening could be
mastered but we cannot really factor
that in since we've never seen it
utilized in battle
otherwise if Aaron could learn how to
see into the near future in a fight that
could be extremely helpful and would
move him up in this list but we don't
know enough about this mysterious
glimpse into the future in order to take
it into account on this list I had
previously specified in the manga
because the anime has a different
version of the fight between the female
and attack Titan in the manga the female
Titan smashes the attack Titans skull
then runs to the wall and eventually
gets taken down by Mikasa in the anime
after the female Titan starts running
the attack Titans eyes turned blue and
fiery red veins like lava start glowing
on his body he gets up and tackles the
female Titan before she reaches the wall
the attack Titan crushes the female
Titans face and she barely manages to
get away in the anime the attack Titan
in what looks like an avatar form is
clearly winning and the female Titan is
running for its life
it leads us to believe that Eren
definitely would have won the one-on-one
battle if Annie didn't attempt to run
away this list is mostly going off of
the manga which is giving us more
information up to this point so I'm not
factoring in this special form that we
haven't seen since into the list however
if the attack Titan is capable of
entering this opie avatar like state
when in serious danger then he would
move up on this list but since it only
happened in the anime and hasn't
happened since I can't put too much
weight on this mysterious form in this
video number 5 the jaw Titan this one
might surprise some people and it would
have surprised me too if we only saw
yamir's version of the jaw Titan after
all it is the smallest Titan along with
the card Titan so you wouldn't expect it
to be able to do much against the bigger
Titans but you'd be wrong in the manga
Porco Galliard Illustrated what the jaw
Titan power was truly capable of and I
had to rethink everything after that we
learned in chapter 104 that the jaw
Titans powerful jaw and nails can crack
the protective crystal shell that so
Pharr Annie and Miss Tiber have been
able to create around their human bodies
this is huge news since no other
hardening ability could put a dent into
these crystals but the jaw tighten could
his jaws and nails could easily cut
through the Harding abilities of the
other Titans including that of the
armored Titan combine this with the
incredible fast movements of the jaw
Titan and you have a very powerful Titan
especially in a one-on-one battle
Aaron's attack Titan was getting
absolutely destroyed by Galliard JA
titan before me cos it came to the
rescue by cutting the jaw Titans legs it
is also noteworthy that in the past
while he was insulting Reiner for being
the weakest warrior Porco suggested that
Marcel Galliard was the strongest among
the younger generation of Marlee and
warriors it is probably not a
coincidence that one of the strongest
warriors inherited one of the strongest
powers the fact that the jaw Titan is
the swiftest among all of the other
Titans and has a strong jaw nails that
can cut through just about anything
earns him this impressive ranking on
this list number four the beast Titan
just as humanity inside the walls has
their strongest soldier Levi Ackerman
Marley has their strongest warriors Zeke
who is the possessor of the beast Titan
power he is taller than the attack and
armored Titan he stands at 17 metres
rather than 50 meters tall Reiner has
admitted that Zeke is Marley's strongest
warrior the beast Titan also has
hardening abilities and can fight well
in shifter vs shifter situations as we
saw when he easily defeated riders
armored Titan
however the beast titans most dangerous
ability which places him above the jaw
Titan on this list is his throwing
ability he can crush large boulders and
send little pieces flying like bullets
at the enemy he also has amazing aim at
long distances this would mean that
someone with the draw Titan power
despite how fast they are probably could
never make it close enough to the Beast
Titan in a one-on-one battle scenario
the beasts Titan would take out the jaw
Titan who despite his amazing offensive
capabilities has one of the smallest
bodies and thus weakest defense against
attack the other Titans meant
so far on this list might not be able to
land as many hits on him but the beast
Titans shotgun esque attacks with their
wide range combined with his impressive
aim should be able to destroy him before
the jaw Titan ever reaches him Zeek
likely due to his royal blood can also
to an extent control Titans that he
turned using his spinal fluid but this
was not an ability that was possessed by
previous beast Titan users and as a
result cannot be taken into account on
this list since it appears to be unique
to Zeek and not the Titan power itself
nevertheless the power and throwing
ability of the beast Titan earned him a
high and respectable place on this list
number three the Warhammer Titan next up
we have the Warhammer Titan in third
place this was the last Titan revealed
and boy was it worth the wait it's full
metal alchemist like powers are amazing
not only does it have a hardened layer
of skin around it that resembles a
knight's armor it does not seem to have
the flexibility and speed restrictions
that the armored Titan has a seasoned
Eren in his attack Titan form was
getting wrecked by the Warhammer Titan
before Mikasa came to the rescue the
Warhammer Titan can create a variety of
weapons including giant spikes that come
out of the ground and impale its
opponent a long giant Warhammer that
completely destroys any heart and
tightens skin a giant crossbow for even
longer distance battle a giant sword a
giant cat-o'-nine-tails
whip that can slice buildings like
butter and so on to boot the Warhammer
Titan shifter does not even have to be
in the Titan but below ground in a
protective crystal shell while
controlling the Titan body very
overpowered abilities indeed the boar
hammer Titans wide variety of weapons
gives it the edge over the previously
mentioned Titans in my view the crossbow
is arguably even more accurate than the
beast Titans rocks the Warhammer Titan
can also create many spikes to trap or
at least slow down the other Titans
weapons with a wide range like the
cat-o'-nine-tails whip would even make
hard for the speedy jaw Titan to dodge
if it can even avoid being impaled by
the ground spikes in the first place
against the beast Titans ace in the hole
it's throwing abilities I feel like the
Warhammer Tyne could easily avoid the
damage by creating a giant shield or a
giant wall to block the crush boulders
for these reasons I feel like this Opie
Titan power deserves to be ranked so
high on this list you know one on one
match its abilities to create a wide
variety of weapons adapted to the
situation at hand given a huge advantage
over the previously mentioned Titans
number two the colossal Titan in second
place we have the first Titan shifter we
saw in the anime the colossal Titan
himself this Titan also called the god
of destruction warps all of the other
Titans mentioned on this list in size it
stands at 60 metres tall it's slow but
makes up for now with its size strength
and special abilities its giant size
alone makes it one of the strongest
Titans using the power that adult was
able to destroy she gonna Sheena
districts gate with one kick I don't
think any of the previously mentioned
Titan powers could significantly damage
the colossal Titan at least from what
we've seen so far the attack Titan could
do absolutely nothing against the
colossal Titan in order to defeat the
colossal Titan Eren and Armin had to
work together come up with a good and
suicidal plant and get Bethel to let
down his guard before they could
actually beat him
Ryanair before said that the colossal
Titan is supposed to be the strongest of
all except that Berthold never used it
to its full potential because of his own
insecurities and his inability to think
for himself in the heat of battle in the
official guidebook the colossal Titan
got it off the charts score of 11 out of
10 in power compared to someone like the
beast Titan who got 7 out of 10
obviously pure power is not the only
factor worth taking into account but I
wanted to help illustrate how
exceptionally large and powerful this
Titan is before getting to his other
special abilities not only is this
already one of the most destructive
Titan powers there is this Titan also
has amazing special abilities one is its
ability to create giant explosions
during its Titan transformation the
explosion creates a mushroom cloud
like an atomic bomb and destroys
anything within its vicinity this is one
of the most destructive attacks in the
attack on Titan universe and it's been
used by Beth Dalton she gan Sheena
district to kill survey corps soldiers
and by Armin to completely annihilate
Marla's naval reinforcements if Bethel
used the power immediately during the
return to Shingo chena arc the Warriors
probably would have won but he didn't
use it immediately because he was
worried about Reiner getting caught up
in the explosion besides this amazing
ability that could take out the other
Titans except for the armored Titan
whose unique armor allows it to
withstand the explosion the colossal
Titan can also control steam in a way no
other Titan can the colossal Titan can
release large amounts of steam from its
body which can repel and/or burn
anything that comes near it
this ability almost killed armand by
burning him to a crisp and blew many
other surrey corps members away such an
ability could act as a possible defense
against long-range weapons like the
beasts titans rocks and the Warhammer
Titans arrows although they probably
wouldn't do much damage even if they did
hit the colossal Titan the only possible
hope that the Warhammer Titan could have
in order to defeat the colossal Titan is
if it managed to avoid its initial
explosion it's burning steam and managed
to somehow create spikes large enough to
effectively impale the colossal Titan
however we've never seen it create
spikes that large while the colossal
Titans other powerful abilities have to
put it above the Warhammer Titan on this
list number one the founding Titan
lastly at number one we have the
founding tighten to tighten that rod
Reese called the greatest of all Titans
Rodri explains that it possesses an
invincible power but Frieda Reese
managed to lose it to Grisha
because she lacked the experience
necessary to exploit its full potential
and Sol was unable to unleash its true
abilities however in this list we are
examining hypothetical Titan shifters
who are able to fully use their titans
abilities so let's look at what a
founding Titan should be able to do just
as the colossal Titan has been called
the god destruction the Titan has been
called God because of its amazing powers
to begin what the founding Titan is able
to
create and control pure Titans it was a
founding Titan that created all of the
millions of colossal Titans in the walls
a founding Titan could potentially use
all of these colossal Titans in battle
along with any other surrounding Titans
or even create more colossal Titans for
the battle it is said that this ability
could flatten the whole world and wipe
out all Titans so the other Titans
couldn't possibly win against it despite
its impressive power and abilities even
the colossal time wouldn't be able to
handle millions of similarly sized
Titans perhaps it could take out some
with its explosion ability but the
others would keep coming until it could
fight no more besides this the patting
Titan power allows its user to
manipulate the memories of subjects of
yamir thus it is possible than a user
who has unlocked the full abilities of
the founding Titan could manipulate the
memories of other shifters we do not
know for sure but perhaps that is how
the Royal Ritz family maintained balance
and peace between the feuding Titan
families as long as they did when Aaron
used the ability to get the surrounding
pure Titans to attack Reiner and Vettel
they were unaffected but they did feel
its influence perhaps the amount of
influence the founding Titan has over
other shifters grows with experience we
cannot be sure but it is possible that
the full unlocking abilities of the
founding Titan could allow the shifter
to manipulate the actions of other
shifters through commands or memory
alterations in this scenario the
founding Titan wouldn't even have to use
colossal Titans to win
lastly the founding team could see the
memories of its past users with perfect
clarity
this knowledge including what must be
knowledge of many previous Titan battles
could no doubt come in handy in a fight
as well for all these reasons this
greatest of all titans this invincible
god as it's been called has to rest at
first place on this list as the
strongest Titan power and that's it for
this video guys thanks so much for
watching
like I said experienced setting planning
and more could change the results of
Titan battles but if each Titan power
was being used to the fullest this is
how I would rank them let me know if you
agree
with this list in the comments or how
you would rank your list and why if you
liked this video don't forget to give
that like button a colossal Warhammer
smash and make it a triple combo by
smashing that subscribe button and magic
youtube Bell for more attack on Titan
videos also feel free to put a
suggestion in the comments for what you
want the next attack on Titan video to
be about and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you